all right everyone bang-bang this is a
thank you
listeners episode what that basically
means is I tweeted out and asked for
questions I literally got hundreds of
questions I'm not going to answer them
all but plana has so graciously agreed
to come on and help me choose the best
ones the best ones that's the best ones
before we do that though I want to
quickly talk about our sponsors these
sponsors today one is block five as you
guys know I'm a super enthusiastic user
and an investor in the company they've
got three products they allow you to buy
and sell crypto in their crypto exchange
they also allow you to deposit crypto
and take out a u.s. dollar alone and
then they allow you to deposit crypto or
stable coins and earn up to eight point
six percent APY in an interest-bearing
account no-brainer compared to
traditional interest-bearing accounts
there's risk go do your own research
also later this year they're gonna come
out with a Bitcoin rewards credit card
it's gonna be awesome go check out black
five.com
slash pump again black Viacom slash pump
our second sponsor is a newer one that
I'm super excited about
it's called choice they've got a new
self-directed IRA product you are
probably listening to this and are part
of the 7.1 million Bitcoin owners who
have retirement accounts with dollars in
them but not big coin that's okay I was
in that situation too but no longer now
you can actually buy a real Bitcoin in
your retirement account I'm talking
about owning your private keys with tax
advantage dollars so you can get a
self-directed IRA called choice that
will allow you to buy Bitcoin own the
private keys and use tax advantage
dollars to do it too it's an absolute
game changer retire with choice dot-com
/ pump retire with choice com / pump
lastly I write a daily letter 50,000
people read it for some reason business
technology and finances when I cover I
break down the complex topics into
easy-to-understand language while
sharing my opinion on various aspects of
each industry you can subscribe at
letter dot-com all right
sponsors are out of the way thank you
for doing this thank you my here's a
wild right now I don't know okay some
people are just listening that's fine
okay what's going on what's the first
question okay first question comes from
Charlie bleaker and bleaker Charlie
let's talk about the process how much
preparation goes into a podcast
interview are your follow-up questions
written out or do they come naturally in
the moment how long did it take you to
interview well for example no filler
words stumbling etc I still don't
interview well I stumble you do I
stutter no you do interview well I
appreciate the compliment I don't think
so I think I can improve drastically I
say um and AH and a bunch of stuff I say
right makes sense
little kind of filler words so I can get
rid of those in terms of preparation it
varies there are some that I do a lot of
preparation but majority I don't do a
lot of preparation I either ask the
guest for specific topics that they
think would be fun to talk about I come
with my own topics and questions but
usually those questions like I know most
of the people who come on the podcast so
there are questions that I already had
and the reason why I'm asking them to
come on the podcast is because I want to
talk to them about something specific
whether it's them an idea they had a
business they've run a view of the world
whatever it is and so part of the magic
I think of the podcast charlie is that I
literally just ask the questions that I
have I don't really worry about what
does the audience think it's my personal
curiosity and so far that's proven to be
super valuable so I'll keep doing it
yeah it's pretty crazy when I I over
prepare and I have to write out every
question he doesn't do that he just
jumps on and he's like let's see where
this takes us which i think is a great
skill to have yeah it's just like a
natural exploration of who is this
person what are their ideas of why do
they care about what they care about I
love it but aren't you ever scared that
you didn't ask them something that you
should have asked them and then later
going back and been like oh I should
have asked that didn't do my research no
I just emailed them and asked them the
question
the get audiences n't get here but like
I still get my answer okay
alright what's the next question TK at
crypto TSK asks who have you learned the
most from who is your most requested
guest that you haven't yet interviewed
um whoever I learned the most from I'll
keep it to somebody on the podcast it's
really hard to pick one person I've
learned so much from so many different
people I would say that the people I've
learned the most from usually end up
having the most views because other
people learn as well so if you think of
just the top the top downloaded episodes
I think it's like shamov raul paul mark
usko Peters a Hanh Mark Cuban Kathy
would like those are the people probably
that everyone would seem that I have
learned the most from one of my
favorites that didn't actually do as
well as I thought it was gonna do was a
with tea through boys from condors fun
I've known Keith for a little bit I just
generally think that he's an incredibly
intelligent guy and the way that he kind
of breaks down problems and the mental
frameworks who use it are super
interesting to me so he's probably
somebody who's not up there and then
another person that I thought was really
interesting was daryl morey
the GM of the Houston Rockets I really
enjoyed talking with him so I think
there's a lot of people in terms of the
second part of the question who is your
most requested guest that you haven't
yet interviewed the most work
what something around podcast everyone
keeps telling me to go on Joe Rogan's
podcast as if like I'm just gonna call
Joe and go like that's not how it works
in terms of people who want a guest to
come on I think I've pretty much got
most of the guests maybe Bill Ackman
yeah well no he's asking me to interview
Beyonce but I think Bill Ackman is
probably the one that I'm still working
on trying to get them they're open to it
so we'll see but he's probably the one
that's the most requests that I haven't
done yet so it is interesting that you
know you've interviewed a lot of people
and you just mentioned the ones you've
learned from yet I have been on your
podcast and I wasn't on that list
well just keep going okay what what what
is the next question okay Michele
McLennan at McLennan is Miche underscore
McLennan where do you begin in learning
about Bitcoin and what are the most
reputable resources of it I send people
to three things I say the first thing
you should do is you should read the
Bitcoin white paper I tend to think that
that is still today one of the best
resources to understand what bitcoin is
and how it was intended to be used the
second thing that I send people to is
Jameson lop has a fantastic resource
page
I think it's lob net slash Bitcoin dot
HTML maybe that is just a fantastic
thing it's got all kinds of links and
videos and it's just like a rabbit hole
unto itself and then the third thing I
send them to is the Bitcoin standard the
book that safe teen wrote I tend to
think that that is a great resource as
well
and so those are the three things I tell
people to start with and if they can
kind of get through those materials I
think they'll come out on the other side
very informed and kind of have a good
understanding of not only what bitcoin
is why it's important and what it's
going to solve in the legacy system
thank you for that question Michelle
next up is Henning at at Henning so it's
the outside eighty underscore heading
Agni I like this question if you were
eighteen years old again what would you
have done differently
if I was 18 years old well first of all
what were you doing at 18 at 18 I had
just gotten to college and I was playing
college football and being a [ __ ]
student my entire freshman year I pretty
much didn't know what the library was on
campus to give you an idea that probably
wasn't the smartest move
and then at 20 I got deployed to Iraq
so pretty much 18 to 20 was like a
normal college kid and then 20 you know
kind of went sideways there but if I can
go back to 18 I think the two things
that I would say to myself was one
surround yourself with people that have
done what you want to do that took me a
little bit in life to understand that
and then the second thing that I
probably would have done differently is
I would have actually not gone to class
I would have done that even more of a
bare minimum and I would spent way more
time learning about the things that I
personally cared about and would have
used college as a way to do that in
terms of advice for my 18 year old self
I think I would literally just tell
myself go bigger go faster and don't
worry about making mistakes yeah but it
was always kind of in the back of my
head of like oh don't screw up because
like no matter how much of an
independent thinker you are or like you
don't care about other people's opinion
you still are scared of like oh my god
like ladies for those who don't know out
of school I started two separate
companies and so never like went to a
job interview or anything while in
college but you're still like oh my god
if these companies don't work like I
have to have something to fall back on
in a safety net and just like that fear
drove me to do things that ended up
being a waste of time at Stephan just
read their handle at sou ste CKY at SU
sticky what do you think about a hybrid
monetary policy like using a neutral
hard asset like Bitcoin as collateral
for central bank currencies seems like a
win for everyone including Bitcoin I
think that we will
see that happen but it will be a
stepping stone to kind of a hyper
Bitcoin eyes dwelled and what that
basically means is there was rumors
already that Venezuela's central bank
was putting Bitcoin and ether into their
reserves at the central bank I do not
know if that was actually true or not it
was a rumor that was floating around it
probably is pretty hard to confirm
either way but I think that that will
happen in the future
they put gold there so why would they
not eventually put Bitcoin and I think
we'll see everyone from kind of the
countries that operate on the fringe
like the Venezuela's the Iran's North
Korea's and no kind of sanction prone to
countries that are superpowers whether
it's the United States Russia China etc
and so I do think that it will happen
it's just not the end State it is merely
a step in the direction of eventually
Bitcoin rising to vehicle wars our
currency can Jimmy play can Jimmy play I
don't know Jimmy can you play if the
price of Bitcoin is less than $17,000
then of 2022 what do you do with your
BTC investment hold it in C or invest
another thing so this is my personal
thing this is obviously not investment
advice for me personally what I'm going
to do is the investment that I've made
in Bitcoin I will not touch as of right
now of course if information changes
like I don't know Bitcoin gets hacked or
something crazy happens then I'll
reevaluate but right now I look at it
very much like a venture investment it's
either gonna be worth an incredible
amount more than it is today over there
whether it's years or decades or it's
gonna be worth very little and worth
much less than it is today I tend to
obviously think it'll be worth way more
but when it's a venture investment what
you basically start to learn is you
don't want to be your own worst enemy so
I'll basically allow the investment to
play out I have a super super long time
horizon I've basically made the
investment and forgot about the money to
some degree and and we'll see what
happens at Chris Vaughn Haim ah Chris oh
you did a podcast with them did would
have you changed your mind about over
this crazy year and why could be
personal one or an economic viewpoint oh
that's a great
question I would say two things probably
have changed my mind on the first is
definitely from an economic standpoint
the Federal Reserve's power to inflate
asset prices and how fast and strong
they can do it
so we've seen a complete dislocation
between the economic realities on the
ground with stock prices we have stocks
hitting all-time highs yet there's 45
plus million Americans that are
unemployed you know all of that type of
something you guys have heard I heard
over and over again from me and others
and so I think the way that I look at it
is that definitely underestimated how
that would work
look at this I'm gonna get a little
light going here sorry hold on a second
guys making my hair look even more crazy
don't have crazy here all right
so that's first of all then I think that
I think personally I've spent a bunch of
time going back and forth on should
companies raise venture capital should
they not who fits in what bucket and I
think that the more time I spent
thinking about it the more that I
realize most companies should not raise
venture capital and not only should they
not raise venture capital but actually
the venture capital could kill them and
so I don't know if that's not changed my
mind as much as I have like gotten a
much deeper conviction in it and it's
caused me to change certain actions that
I take both from an entrepreneurial
standpoint but also from an investing
sample a personal one plane and I have
survived being locked up for four months
together so that's pretty good
I didn't change I didn't change my mind
that's actually a lack of change my mind
I could've changed my mind
okay good like I'm out see you so at
Andre Simon 20 has a concern is it a BTC
standard just replacing the 1% elite
gold standard proved not to be good I
think we need to change the system /
engine not the fuel so I like BTC
and I believe it will change a few
things but not enough so I think that we
actually believe the same thing he is
saying something that is a little bit
short-sighted in the sense of I believe
that Bitcoin changes the system it's not
just changing the fuels change the
national energy because ultimately what
you're doing is you're doing two things
that are very important one you're
removing the human nature involved in
Mont and managing money so literally
you're going to remove the equivalent of
all central banks around the world there
is incredible power and there's a
structure and ownership that comes with
those central banks and so by removing
them you quite literally are changing
the system the second thing that I would
say is there is a kind of ripple effect
or a cascading effect by changing the
money or as my friend Marty Ben says a
lot he says you know fixed the money
fixed the world basically by fixing the
money you fix a lot of other things
everything from the overconsumption in
societies to literally wealth in a bawdy
gap all that kind of stuff and so it's
the single point of failure in the
legacy system that causes the most
damage and so if you can basically fix
that or improve it
I think Bitcoin does that you then can
also kind of the ripple effect of
improving all the other things and so
it's the ultimate changing of the system
or improving of the system yeah very
interesting
at caveman CJ what is the most simple
yet profound statement about Bitcoin
that you can tell someone to make them a
believer
favorite one I don't know if it's the
most profound or anything like that my
favorite one to tell people is do you
think the system's broken and most
people will say yes and then I tell them
bitcoin is a peaceful protest about
leaving that system and they me to go
what do you mean
and it it's intriguing enough to get
them to ask questions and try to
understand it more and so I like to go
down the path of like hey this is a
protest of the existing system done in a
peaceful way because it's just enough
kind of revolutionary and intriguing and
kind of pulls on certain emotional
strings to get somebody to ask questions
and dig deeper but at the same time it's
still accurate enough to clearly
articulate this is something that is
outside of the system or something that
is going to be quite different than the
existing system there's a whole lot of
systems that are broken just that fire
okay grant
Oh what's your bare thesis for Bitcoin
does unlimited QE help or hurt Bitcoin
in the next three to five years the more
money they print the more [ __ ] is
for Bitcoin in my personal opinion my
bare thesis is and I've continued to say
this for a while now the number one way
that Bitcoin suffers or ultimately ends
up being not valuable is from a
self-inflicted wound and so that can be
everything from literally a software bug
is introduced in the development process
obviously there's a lot of things in
place to try to mitigate those but
that's one possibility another
possibility is that there's some sort of
bitcoiners that do that participate in
like a 51% attack or something like that
again unlikely there's things in place
to try to mitigate that but but that's
potential and and also we've seen in
history how that hasn't worked and then
the last thing that I would say is the
bare thesis I'm not gonna put this in
the bare thesis category but it is a
potential barrista so I actually don't
think it'll be a bear situation many
people do is outright banning
of ownership in the United States or
elsewhere so if the US government said
hey we're gonna ban others should be
Bitcoin obviously that would have a
short-term negative impact I personally
think you would have a very very
positive long-term impact
but nobody knows for sure and so some
people have put that the bearish
category I put it in kind of the neutral
positive category but you know hopefully
we never find out at Mao quest-19 how
did you get your lady into crypto asking
for a friend
she's not into crypto that's the truth I
appreciate it yeah plenty up one
understands much more than most people
obviously she just hears me blabbing
about it all time to is she grew up in
Eastern Europe and literally when she
was growing up her home country of
Bulgaria went through their own version
of hyperinflation and so she and her
family experienced that and the third
thing that I would say is we take a very
interesting type of investment strategy
between the two of us I take lots and
lots of risk and we've consciously made
a decision for planted to do as little
risk as possible in her portfolio and so
so far so good yeah I think just if
you're talking about getting her
interested in it I think that just
explaining it in a way that makes sense
and has explains the practical
applications of it helps okay um at wah
wah nas so wound odds do you see did you
see anything in the army that changed
your perception of your country yeah I
think any soldier who's ever gone to
combat zone basically starts to see war
for what it is there's an agenda and
that's true of every single war ever in
history some of it is very much
explainable and kind of reasonable then
there's other times where people are
just like why are we here what are we
doing and I think that that is an
eye-opening experience especially for a
20 21 year old soldier who kind of
joined for what most people would say
like the quote unquote right reasons of
patriotism and things like that
and the second thing that I would say is
war is this really weird place where you
see the best of humanity and you also
see the worst of humanity and sometimes
you can see that in the same moment or
in the same day and so I think you just
get a lot of kind of whiplash in terms
of the extremes of humanity it can leave
you very jaded it can leave you actually
very positive on humanity and so I think
that's probably one of the things that
was most interesting was just I mean I
came back and I most people who know me
know that like when I came back I was
like I could die at any second like I'm
going to have the most fun ever in life
and I just I didn't necessarily go wild
in the sense of like people think like
partying and doing all that kind of
stuff but I just took this approach of
like I'm gonna live life to the fullest
and a friend of mine used to say in high
school anything worth doing is worth
overdoing
and I kind of take that to heart of just
like that I tend to agree that that's a
pretty good way to live life well I just
but what I will say is he never gets
stressed I worry about every little
thing and you just never worry which may
be your best quality and and stress does
not affect you in the same way that it
affects other humans is it because you
keep that in the back of your mind I
talked about this before
I basically compartmentalize things and
I evaluate every single potential
stressful thing or threat or whatever
eyes can I die no it's not important but
that's tough right why because there's
so many things that are not imminent
death but you still get stressed about
like family families health family
members health like things like that
that you know you worry about I can't do
anything about it so it's what's in your
control yeah just am I gonna die no okay
then I can't stress about it maybe I can
you know talk to them or whatever I just
um be strapped why would I get stressed
okay Patrick Callan e @p Cowan naeli
sorry I brought sure that at peak Allen
Ely serious question I really
this question can you dive into I read
the internet would love to know how you
find filter and consume information so
for those that don't know Flynn and I do
a daily YouTube show and there's many
times where I don't know the topics
beforehand plano will start talking
about soy and i'll start rattling off
stats or intricacies of the story and
she'll look at me and say how do you
know that and i'll always respond in a
very arrogant and obnoxious way with i
read the internet and so what that
really means is i just spent a lot of
time consuming information and i try my
best to make sure that it's high-quality
information obviously there's no filter
that's perfect in terms of where I get
that information yeah yeah where I get
the information I would say there's
three main sources so one is I have the
advantage and pleasure of talking to may
the smartest wealthiest most successful
people in the world for the podcast and
so you know many of those people I've
met before and they bring them on the
podcast but there's plenty of people who
I'm meeting for the kind of first time
as well but those conversations are
incredibly valuable in terms of just
being well educated and well-read and
kind of understanding many parts of the
world
another thing is on Twitter I follow a
lot of people and I pretty much have you
know kind of mentally in a very loose
way categorized people of like high
signal low signal some people I
literally followed just for the memes
and I don't take anything they say too
seriously some people I follow
literally from like a competitive
analysis standpoint if companies were
invested in or something like that and
then some people I follow could I think
they're incredibly intelligent and I
literally turn on notifications and when
they tweet I want to see what they're
saying and the last thing I would say is
I read a lot of newsletters yeah I
listen to podcast - yeah but the
newsletters I think are much more kind
of informative in terms of like current
events and what's going on and analysis
and things like that the podcast to me
are much more they replace something
akin to like business school if you will
so I want to hear people's stories I
want to hear how they did certain things
why they made certain decisions in the
past how they worked out where they do
things differently things like that so
podcast I listen to or Joe Rogan Tim
Ferriss Jacko will make Eric Weinstein
Patrick o'Shaughnessy's and
like the best 20 minute VC Harry
Stebbings there's a whole bunch of them
but those are all can you share the news
letters you read newsletters that I read
the ones that I open every single week
without fail one is the profile for sure
the profiles is both because she would
hold a gun to my head and also because
actually enjoy reading profile calm
that's the one I read for sure every
week a second one is I read Peters a Han
pretty much every single day I think
he's pretty good Polina is gonna kill me
for this one of the people who I think
is very intelligent
plenty used to run a better newsletter
but doesn't is Dan Primack I think I
think Dan just has a very nuanced way to
look at the world
I really enjoyed Josh Constantine's work
and then there's like a bunch of other
ones that I don't actually subscribe to
what I do is that wait till people that
I know are high signal tweet them and
then I'm gonna go click and read them
and so I basically am waiting for like
other people to filter the ones that are
the highest quality and then when they
tweet them then I go read them but I
just know who those people are that are
likely to one have a good filter and two
also tend to share the things that they
read sorry can I just dig into that a
little bit more sure okay how do you
identify somebody as high signal it's
somebody who whether I agree with what
they're saying or not it's obvious that
they have a very strong mental framework
for how they think through things and
actually another thing would be people
that I've seen change their mind in
public is a great one and then a third
thing I would say is something beautiful
about Twitter's like it's not just kind
of your best self put forward so
somebody may say something and people
will respond and then they get engaged
in a conversation and you can pretty
quickly tell like oh that person is
intelligent or like that person had a PR
person write that tweet and like
literally I don't know like they just
have water
in their school right there's no there's
no brains in there and so I think that
you can just kind of triangulate it
there's no like science to is more of an
art but once you get to that point then
you're just like hey what are other
smart people I know reading and so
that's what Ben Thompson strategy
obviously as I've got no brainer I read
to Parrish yes Farnum should I read on
Sunday okay Matt zero sixteen seven one
four oh four you recently went on the
bill burr Bert podcast bills Bert
podcast what is it bill Bert podcast his
name is Bill burr but then he's a
co-host okay was bill burr more
receptive to Bitcoin at the end than you
anticipated new wants to answer but a
lot of people don't remember this bill
burr was an absolute animal back in the
2008 crisis and coming out of it
he was just roasting the federal reserve
go google or go on youtube and type in
bill burr Federal Reserve like hilarious
take down to the Federal Reserve so he's
actually very very well versed in in
finance the Federal Reserve monetary
system things like that he doesn't let
on as much which makes it funnier but
he's very intelligent obviously Bert was
much less up the curve and he I think
even said that the podcast like he was
just learning and was super fascinated
by everything in terms of the
receptiveness I did not expect bill burr
to say on the podcast like you know
screw it I'm gonna go buy Bitcoin that
is yes and then in terms of Bert like
Bert very quickly grabbed on to things
that are nuanced in terms of mining and
things like that so I generally think
that people who would reach out to me
and say hey like will you come on talk
about Bitcoin they're open-minded
already there's some level of interest
or intrigue but to see kind of how far
down the rabbit hole they went so
quickly was awesome cool at Travis
Riegler you were Oh what are you doing
it's cleaning the screen oh yeah you
were in the military before how did you
pivot to a job at face
I'm trying to learn programming to pivot
to a software engineer and I'm finding
it to be difficult so I didn't
necessarily go from the military right
into into the software I don't know why
this lights being okay in terms of how I
got there so I was in the army and then
I went back to school basically after
deployment and at that point I decided
to start a company it was we claim that
it was successful but frankly it was not
nearly as successful we wanted it to be
and it was kind of a great learning
experience I basically didn't lose money
which was a whole in in my book at the
time the second company that I started
then went much better and that really
allowed me to kind of springboard in so
what I would say is there's two ways to
build a resume that can get you into one
of the tech companies large tech
companies the first is you can go the
traditional path through education or
the second thing is you can build things
that they find interesting and they
being people who work at the companies
and that's essentially how I got in was
I built some tools around social data
that people at Facebook have found
interesting and so I ended up getting
the the job that way okay
Jeana oh god Glasgow besides regulation
and opposition from the banking industry
what do you imagine is Kryptos biggest
hurdle the widespread common usage for
individuals and businesses time time for
just takes time like you're literally
asking people to go use new products or
to go use new money it takes time to
build trust like it's only ten years old
Gold's been around for 5000 years the US
dollar not backed by Gold's been around
since 1971 like this stuff just takes a
long time and you know that's a super
shitty answer in the sense of people
wanted to be immediate but at the end of
the day it literally just takes more
time and so I think that people have to
kind of have something called urgent
patients which means on a day-to-day
basis you have to have a sense of
urgency and get things done and keep
iterating and building and shipping
products and kind of really pushing the
the pace of innovation in the short-term
but also understand and be able to zoom
and have kind of the intellectual
honesty of like hey this isn't gonna
happen overnight like bitcoin is a
multi-decade play and you have to be
comfortable with the fact that you've
got to work your ass off every single
day in the short term in order to earn
the right for Bitcoin to be successful
over decades so what I found interesting
is that last year we were in Bulgaria
and literally my grandmother who does
not speak English and Anthony we're
talking through me as a translator about
Bitcoin like she knew more than I think
I expected my grandmother in Bulgaria to
know so do you think she's in it just so
people know she's an accountant and her
bosses at work she works at a pretty
large pretty large corporation her
bosses at work were mining Bitcoin and
so she basically think they had told her
about it but she's in her 60s
no yes yes she is she's in her 60s and
she lives in Bulgaria literally like in
the suburb not suburbs I got a farm
basically and and she knew about Bitcoin
and like and didn't know just like oh
I've heard of Bitcoin like was able to
explain to me like oh my bosses are
mining with computers to earn Bitcoin
things like that and so I think again
like that that's that is an outlier like
most people in Bulgaria probably don't
know about Bitcoin my question is do you
think that adoption is different places
do you think it'll the time the time
that it takes to adopt it is
significantly shorter in something of
course like if your currency fails
tomorrow all of a sudden you're like
[ __ ] I need dollars or what's the next
best thing
Yeah right and so of course there's
things that can happen to accelerate it
but all but overall on a global basis
and be kind of average everything yeah
I'm just going to take time at Jimmy Mac
257 what company are you investing in
that you think and create them must have
app that can drive complete mainstream
crypto adoption people hate this answer
but it's Bitcoin I ultimately think
Bitcoin is going to be the killer app I
think bitcoins going to be the most
popular popular product and there will
be all kinds of things built around it
whether it's wallets its exchanges you
know every piece of infrastructure you
can imagine neo banks that the whole
line is payment processors whatever but
ultimately bitcoin is going
to be the core of all of this it's
already done a fantastic job over eleven
years I think it's only getting started
it will continue and you know I'm pretty
honest with with the idea that I believe
Bitcoin will be the next global reserve
currency and the whole idea is that we
don't need humans in order to kind of
control or manipulate the currency we
can have a programmatic transparent you
know well understood monetary policy and
I think Bitcoin provides that ok I like
this question at Satoshi underscore
fever
if holiness portfolio outperforms yours
will there be trouble in the household
Polina will be a billionaire before me
fact how do you know that so many today
but I do believe in play no more than
she lose herself sometimes no that's not
true
sometimes it's true but I appreciate you
believing in me cuz I believe myself ok
anyway so we always joke that I there's
some products that I use that he has
never heard of and then they like get
sold for a it's not just some products
Polina has been an early user of like
six different companies that end up
going on these billion dollar companies
what are they millennial women glossier
Rent the Runway stitch fix drunk
elephant what was on canva and I was
like the earliest user you're using
camping with two thousand thirteen
fourteen thirteen whatever but like so
it does go to this whole idea of like
millennial women or younger girls tend
to actually be on top of these trends
they gossip a lot so they talk to each
other and they spread stuff through word
about will gossip being like
word-of-mouth they just spread something
by the way guys gossip too it's just
they just gossip about dumb [ __ ] like
what's the score the football game they
don't talk about like yo dude do you see
the new face wash I have yeah in glossy
I used to be a cult blog before it was
ever a company so if you knew it through
that you know also I was an early
subscriber of the skin like all that
stuff what's next next ready yeah wait
no recording this at nine o'clock so
those who are watching the video and
think that we look tired it's not that
we're tired
look tired at all Louise geom question
who are the five non-obvious people you
have consistently read and followed for
over a year in terms of valuable signal
or perspective in any category also
choices don't have to be Twitter or
podcasts this is really hard because the
people that I've probably fought for a
long time like over a year on the
Internet they probably get discovered by
most people like I would certainly
investor no no but just like so here's a
good example of somebody who like
recently lots and lots of people started
to pay attention to
Blake Robbins at Ludlow Ventures Blake
has been on top of media consumer
technology gaming like a bunch of things
and I've always just kind of like I met
him and a couple years ago always
thought he was a very intelligent guy
again great mental frameworks really
understood things was very personable I
was willing to admit when he changed his
mind like all all the things that I look
for in people who I think are
intelligent but now he's like you know
which reason I'm Patrick o'Shaughnessy's
invest like the best podcast he's met
pretty much everyone adventure everyone
likes him so like he's kind of no longer
like a secret commodity if you will in
terms of like his thoughts and ideas in
terms of other people that I think or
interesting Morgan Housel Morgan Housel
is fantastic yeah but like again like
he's like a unknown person now right so
like most of the people who end up being
good end up getting exposed and exposed
in a positive way like Shane Parrish is
another one right like even you right
like when you started three years ago
nobody knew about the profile now all of
a sudden tens of thousands of people
know about it right so it's like if you
do something on the internet for long
enough and have consistency of high
quality like eventually you get
discovered and that's like a really
weird thing to say because most people
think it's like around like old musician
or a performer or something but it's
also true of like intellectuals as well
hmm okay at Dylan Koch - if BTC is to
exceed a 10x return do you think that
stifles innovation in the short term
because entrepreneurs would rather stack
sacks that's
our business no I think most
entrepreneurs especially in the venture
world they're using other people's money
to build the businesses so they're not
necessarily going to not use their money
to start a business if anything if
Bitcoin ends up appreciating a ton in
u.s. dollar value it'll bring more and
more people who want to build products
around Bitcoin so it actually will lead
to more business creation rather than
less lane or eating done 24 what happens
first
Giants win another Super Bowl or humans
on Mars damn I think humans all Mars
Edie come on bro come on don't go be
coming at me like that John's going no
Superbowl don't worry we got Daniel
jones sake one game on let's go by the
way if the Giants go eight and eight
that means they got a shot to win the
Superbowl
if we do really well in the regular
season we're getting bounced first round
playoffs get bounced that's right okay
oh do you think the light is like that
cuz I moved at bully
esque son at Billy Squier oh sorry son
that's not what it says okay you know
the guy you call crypto bully this is a
pair of yukata oh my god oh but this is
not the crypto boy it's a son at a pump
lianna
will you run for presidency in 2024 no I
like my private life I have zero
interest in politics but to be what I
what I will say is I believe that
somebody's gonna win on this ticket and
if somebody put a gun to my head and
said you had to run what would your
strategy be
I would not run as an individual I would
put together a team and I would run is
like as a team well here's what I would
say is okay here's the president here's
the vice president here's every single
person that's in the cabinet here like
here's everybody and then I would go to
the debates and if they asked me a
question about national security I say
listen I understand enough about
national security to answer this
question but actually I have this expert
who's on my team I'm gonna defer to them
and delegate this what do you think what
I would do is basically I would bring
the smartest people the most experienced
people in the world together and I would
say to the American people that look
you're not voting for me you're voting
for this team and I'm not arrogant
enough to believe that I'm an expert in
all these different things or the best
most well-versed instead I'm gonna build
a team that together we cannot be beaten
by anyone in the world yeah so to add to
that one interesting thing you've told
me is that when you work at Facebook you
genuinely believes that the company was
successful because it brought in some of
the smartest people at the time around
the table and it was it would iterate on
many things can you talk about the
importance of having like a team of
incredibly smart people when people
respect each other and they know that
everyone there is intelligent like
people would literally say things like
well you got in here so like you're not
an idiot right and when you respect each
other and you are all bought into the
goal of solving a problem it's it's
incredible what can happen there's very
special things I think politics is a
great example where what you do is when
you build that team you actually build
it in a bipartisan way so you literally
have Republicans Democrats and
independents all on the team so that
there's no kind of party politics or any
of that stuff and you basically just
show up you say listen here's the deal
we as a team all believe in these core
principles and we are going to do
everything we can to accomplish these
goals and any problem that comes up we
feel like we have the intellectual
horsepower and the experience and
expertise on our team to solve it and by
the way if you think you as an
individual who we are running against is
smarter than us knock yourself out but
as the American people are you gonna
vote for a team of experts are you gonna
vote for you know one person and I think
that somebody will win with that
strategy I don't know if that's in 2024
or beyond but I just see that being a
very very strong strategy especially in
the world that we live today with
digital media at glance at explaining
Bitcoin of people is challenging what's
your advice to money that's it
mine is a belief system so is Bitcoin
that's why it has value and then it
literally I always go to the monopoly
example so many of you probably heard me
say it but I basically say look when you
play Monopoly there's four people
sitting down at a table everyone puts
their bank balance in front of them
right all of their money then there's a
bank
where there's no actual banker right
somebody in the game is just close to it
they are doing everything but the reason
why I'm monopoly works is because you
can see every single transaction that
occurs all the transactions between
people and also the transactions with
the bank and it's simply because of
transparency if you play with somebody
who puts the money underneath the table
then all of a sudden everyone thinks
they're cheating so you say pour the
money back on top of the table
same thing with Bitcoin Bitcoin is
essentially a digital version of that
transparent system of transactions and
it's just done in a super secure way
that is backed by the strongest
competing network in the world it's just
super easy like people everyone's the
monopoly right if you haven't and like
get together okay a try three done what
is your least favorite part about having
a podcast least favorite I got no
complaints like even the things that are
behind you yeah like I mean like even
the parts that are like less desirable
are still awesome I literally have no
complaints at all I say at all times the
most selfish thing I do I learned so
much from the podcast I record the
conversation so other people can hear
but ultimately I'm asking the questions
on you know intellectually curious about
and so it's super self-serving from a
learning perspective for me you know
very thankful that all of you listen to
it you know literally thank you that's
why I'm doing this right now is try to
answer as many questions as I can but
ultimately there's nothing that I can
complain about I got a pretty good life
oh-hoo outside of your immediate family
has most influenced you in life and how
so I saw this this little cheating here
no plane is my family so she doesn't
care but what I would say would cover
for not answering me what I would say
here is the most influential people are
actually people that nobody would
recognize when I went to Iraq at 20
years old there was a number of guys who
it sounds cliche but like they literally
forced me to grow
and like Nam this is like become a man
but in the sense of I was a 20 year old
like [ __ ] kid playing college
football going to class barely and like
wondering like when's the next party
right and then I was thrown into this
environment where I deployed with a
number of guys who were much older than
me many of them kind of in the early to
mid 30s they had wives they had kids
that mortgages like they were you know
grown-ups in my mind and I say Kim [ __ ]
about you get her old but really what
they ended up teaching me is they taught
me about personal responsibility you
know frankly they helped keep me safe I
hopefully kept them safe and they
basically just gave me this edge of like
no [ __ ] we get things done and we're
going home and I think that that like
mental fortitude or mental sharpness and
kind of strength hopefully I still kind
of use it today but you know guys like
if they're listening they'll get a crack
out of this but guys like you know Tony
Weber micki least or more cash you know
we're not gonna use his real name we
just use cash okay you know there's all
kinds of guys like literally I can think
of so many and I'll just use them
because they were probably the ones I
was the closest with but I think they're
probably most influential in this sense
that's cool Oh have you been in Bulgaria
if yes what did you like the most and
please don't say the identical donkey
carriages on the streets yeah I've been
to Bulgaria a couple of times I don't
know what three four times now and the
part that I like the most is it's what I
like about everywhere like humans are
humans so you can literally go anywhere
in the world
I don't speak though and in five
sentences seven said this is something
like that I can basically say that clean
is annoying me I can tell everyone in
her family I love them I can tell every
woman in her family that they're
beautiful I cash from the bathroom is I
can say no
yeah I can say yes like and I've got
down the fact that Bulgarians when they
are saying yes they shake their head
left and right and when they say no
they're nodding up and down which is the
opposite of Americans so like I'm pretty
well-versed for for an American dude but
I I think that just like from a human
perspective it doesn't matter if I speak
the language or not like you can just
get along with people and it's pretty
cool just to see kind of that humanity
in in other countries
he struck a friendship with my
grandmother's like eighty five year old
neighbor who has all sorts of animals in
his thing and he always asks about him
that's my guy the second the first time
I ever met him I don't know sir but
first time I ever met him I was sitting
in her grandma's Villa
and all of a sudden I heard a commotion
behind me that you know american-themed
up it was like what the hell's going on
and also here comes this guy you know
relatively older kind of bumbling in and
he's got a wheelbarrow and it's covered
with a piece of tin on top of it and the
guys literally got on like adidas slides
sandals a sweat pants like kind of an
old looking jacket and a hat like a
winter hat and you know looks like me
maybe didn't shower last couple days
yeah he comes in and so like I didn't
know who he was and plane wasn't
standing there so I couldn't like who is
this guy and all of a sudden he's got
this grin on his face he's just looking
at me he's like hype and I'm like okay I
think this is like a friendly situation
and then her grandmother comes to plate
it comes on stuff and oh he's the
neighbor he's the neighbor help with the
wheelbarrow so I'm like what the hell is
in this thing's like pretty heavy and
all of a sudden this guy like he can't
wait till I get the wheelbarrow down
into kind of like near the door and all
of a sudden he starts pointing at me
pointing at the wheelbarrow and he pulls
off the tin in the tin underneath the
tin in the wheelbarrow was literally he
had taken one of the sheep that he's
yeah basically what he's done is he has
literally since birth taking care of
this animal and he killed it and cooked
it because I was there
crazy it's just a little oh yeah but
like but the fact that like he was he
was so kind and like and he was so happy
like literally he was happy as doing
something for somebody else
damn the guy just like me yeah he like
be like okay I see Thanks equity pool
what are your goals that you've set for
your podcast YouTube newsletters over
the next five years
I don't do five-year goals I pretty much
only set goals for the year and even
that's like a stretch for me a lot of
times it's just you know a month to six
months mainly because the world changes
too much in five years and like my
personal interest changes so much like
teh I'm 32 years old and I have a fiance
but not married no kids except like when
you're five years later your life is so
different so how can you actually set a
goal that's five years away that's
pretty hard and the second of all is
like things change so like what's a
newsletter today that platform may
evolve or do something different so just
really hard to set those goals in terms
of this year the goals were to get the
podcast to a million downloads per month
we already hit that to get YouTube to a
hundred thousand subscribers which was
gonna be like a 20x for us we're at like
seventy five seventy six thousand so
we're kind of ahead of schedule there
and the newsletter I didn't really set
any goals those more of just like
basically just keep consistently pumping
out the content every morning and to me
that's more of like a discipline and
consistency thing and so far we've kept
that so so far so good for the year but
but I don't know necessarily what all
this becomes I don't have some master
plan I just kind of keep rolling with
the punches and making decisions on a
day-to-day basis I think's the right
thing to do at dreams lack six when
you're up what are you optimistic about
for 2021 and beyond that others may be
more bearish outside a Bitcoin I'm long
humans in long America like I generally
think that right now a lot of people are
looking around and being like man
America is getting torn apart like civil
wars on
the horizon you know innovation has gone
out the window
there's a incredible encroachment on
civil liberties and personal freedoms
you know all the things that you just
see people talking about I agree with a
lot s I've actually the short term but
just over a long period of time I tend
to be just very very long American
ingenuity creativity and entrepreneurial
spirit and so that's probably the one
that right now especially in an economic
shock a pandemic all this crazy [ __ ]
that's going on 2020 I tend to be pretty
optimistic over a long period of time
but what do you think that do you think
that you know especially if America
becomes more closed off and we don't
allow immigrants in as much as we used
to do you think they'll go to other
countries and build businesses I don't
worry about that as much because I don't
think that that's a long-term
sustainable thing is to close off your
country I generally think that the
internet and other technologies are
globalizing the world rather than
nationalizing things yes sure they're
certain whether it's politicians or
individuals or wealthy elites you know
whatever that want different things but
generally the trend is towards
globalization and we also live in the
most prosperous safe time in human
history like if you look at the long
term trends that tends to be
good-looking demographics like Peter
Zaman talks about this a lot the
demographics is the demographics of the
United States are incredible compared to
a lot of countries around the world and
it generally is just summed up is like
if anyone's gonna get through this is
America and if we can't then okay then
everyone else gonna have a really hard
time to that and by the way that's not
like American exceptionalism in terms of
like we have to win everyone has to lose
it's more so like it's not a binary game
and I grew up here I was born here I
live here now and so I generally want to
see like my fellow citizens and my
country do well it doesn't have to be at
the expense of other countries I
actually want to see everyone do well it
just feels like I spent a lot of time
evaluating and analyzing America we have
all been ingredients necessary to be
successful the future is this your
platform for 2024 okay I would like go
to one debate and I would drop like six
f-bombs and just be like urine
and then they'd be like you're not
invited back and I entrepreneur within a
nascent industry that is attacking
legacy systems for finance how do you
position building your brand and thought
leadership for blockchain slash crypto
and entrepreneurship in jungle yeah a
lot of people ask me about this brand
building stuff like I don't think about
it you don't focus on building my no I
just yeah but I just the less than I
have for everyone is just like just be
you like I literally say what I believe
and a lot of people censor themselves I
if I say I actually believe it and that
gets a lot of people in trouble look
I've said things people like attack me
and get upset what everybody I don't
care I literally do not care I'm gonna
say what I want to say because I want to
say it and you know plain and I have
both talked about this before but like I
genuinely believe the most the utmost
form of freedom is to have your identity
tied to your personal name so when
somebody asked me who are you I don't
say oh I'm an investor or I've got this
or that or what like those are things
that I do but my identity is tied to my
name and I tend to think that that is
you know kind of quote a brand but
really it's just that just being
authentic and that's what's been able to
put me in that position okay how many
more questions do we have time for let's
keep going okay I promised I'd answer as
many as I could okay Kimberly Jo now at
you are the wealth what is your why I
just want to have fun that's literally
it
I want to have fun and be happy I can
attest about like people people in every
walk of my life had asked me this
question and that's genuinely what I
want to do is I want to just have fun
and be happy and other than that I don't
care I still remember we were at this
panel place in this bougie guy was like
what why are you doing this like what's
the point of all this and he was like I
just want to be happy and he was like no
like for real like I'm not joking like
what's crazy he was shook when I was
like no see like you may not actually be
doing it for this but that's
and by the way that also means like the
day that I stopped having fun or being
happy they call just stop I'll literally
one day I'm gonna wake up and just be
like yep that's it I'm not writing u s--
letter anymore none to the podcast I'm
not tweeting any more like see guys and
oh I'll keep doing that until uh until I
stop being happy or having fun I don't
think that's gonna happen anytime soon
but it's just generally how I feel at
Dakota Street do what you're good at or
do what you're passionate about I think
you generally are good at what you're
passionate about mainly because you just
spend so much time on it sure I don't
know yeah I'm sure there's you know the
outlier situations like hey I'm
passionate about basketball but I'm
five-six more like yeah sure okay but
like you can do other things in
basketball right you could be a coach
you can be a referee you could you know
be a sports analyst do whatever so I
just I think these are all like false
dichotomies in terms of like what you're
good at what you're passionate at just
like just do this [ __ ] that makes you
happy right and like whatever that is
like I promise you you'll end up being
good at in the beauty of it is like for
example with the profile I write this
newsletter every Sunday and I've been
asked aren't you afraid that somebody's
just gonna replicate it and it's like
because I'm so passionate about it and
because I know just how many hours I put
into it and it's hard work I'm not
afraid of that because I just I know
that nobody would be able to do the work
if they're not passionate about it the
way that I am of course okay I J so V
are trying to get my daughter's 16 and
14 excited about blockchain in its
future any suggestions on motivating
them and the best platform for them to
learn more about it yeah again like I
don't have kids so it's hard for me to
kind of say hey this is what you should
do yeah what I generally think the best
thing to do is actually start with the
problems and if you explain to them
things like what's going on a Lebanon
right now where they've seen the
currency class more than 50 percent I
tend to think that's interesting the
second thing is part of me says like
don't force them to learn about it right
because I think that it's really hard to
do that instead what you basically want
to do is you want to just give them the
technology like young kids are so
digitally native that they'll figure it
out it's
like just give us some Bitcoin and see
what happens and just watch for a little
bit and I bet you that they end up
figuring it out like going cash out for
something and they see you know they'll
start telling you like what stores
accept Bitcoin almost crazy stuff so I
don't necessarily there's like oh go
read this book review this thing as much
as it is just like introduce kids to
expose them to it and then just kind of
let them run wild like they're so smart
literally kids come up to me all the
time and I'm just like Jesus literally
you know how to do things with my phone
that I didn't even know existed right
and I tend to think that I'm pretty
well-versed a lot of this stuff so I
think at James white neck same question
you asked to end Alex Fenske podcast
what's one thing that you haven't seen
yet that you wish was written about
thought or explored this is gonna be
very controversial but I think that
there's a massive problem with the
mainstream media or legacy media right
now and the number one thing I think
that could expose that and expose it not
in like a attacking way but just an
understand - you think this is an
academic issue this is not a like who
can dunk on who on Twitter I think that
the way that things have been covered
has changed drastically some of that is
out of necessity from a business model
that's been well covered in a bunch of
you know analysis and pieces and things
like that some of it's also the changing
of the platforms so obviously the way
that you write is going to cater to
whatever platform you're using and what
I would love to see is a analysis on
things like what words have been used
sentence structures length of articles
topics that are covered how frequently
by what publications like just like a
super deep data-driven analysis of how
the legacy media has changed over listen
last 50 to 100 years and I want to make
sure that it's clear that like I
actually have an open mind and like that
change I could be sold on the idea that
is actually a positive not a negative
right it's not necessarily that it has
to be a negative outcome because of it
but I do think that there's been a big
change and so it's one of these things
where like I think a lot of people
including next sitting next to me as a
former journalist at a very well-known
publication
it just feels like we don't have a good
understanding of the data of what's
changed it's all anecdotal would that
help tell you so one of the things that
I've seen that got me thinking about
this is I won't say who it is but
somebody showed me a study of the use of
what they categorized as like woke words
or left-leaning words so literally like
the word woke right for example they
analyzed after the New York Times put up
their pay wall how many more times they
started to use those words and there was
act like an explosion wasn't like both
20% more it was like because there came
a thousand percent more yes so what ends
up happening is the explanation whether
it's accurate or not that was in this
study basically was explaining that well
if you have a pay wall people pay you
you're gonna write to keep the
subscriber rather than write things that
they don't like because then we'll
unsubscribe and so naturally it just
pulls you in a direction right so left
leaning people will start writing more
left-leaning stuff lately and people
start reading more right leaning stuff
whatever and so you kind of get pulled
in the extremes my guess is that that's
like a very small difference and part of
this is like from me looking at it with
an open mind it's like until we have the
data it's really hard to make kind of
conclusions I'm like here's what's
happened right or like is it good is it
bad it's not it just feels like it is
different and it would be actually
interesting to see like the data show us
that it's not different right but like
the fact that we're humans and we're
idiots and we're really bad at
predicting the world and understanding
the world we need the data to understand
what's changing so I think seeing that
interesting hi you think it'd be
interesting yeah thanks Frank the bowl
and one what happens when central bank's
balance sheets exploit we've seen this
you know many times before but look at
the end of the day every Empire Falls
every currency fails that's inflationary
and so I think what we're gonna see is
the same stuff happen like we again live
in the most prosperous save time in
human history and hopefully that stuff
doesn't happen in my lifetime like it's
super selfish
I don't want to see world chaos right
like I don't want to see the US job I
don't want to see the US dollar filling
any of this stuff but at the same time
like
history suggests that the trends that we
are following we haven't learned from
history right we basically have an
inflationary curse that we continue to
devalue we've got a global monetary
complex that is amazing until it's not
and ultimately you know every country
that ends up dominating the world ends
up falling at some point so like you
know I'm probably got about 50 to 60
more years in my life like let's hold on
to it till it's all I'm gone but uh but
but I just generally think that
eventually that stuff's gonna happen and
so central bank's balance sheet is
exploding like is it really dead if
we're not gonna pay it back and I think
it's hard to argue at this point 20-plus
trillion dollars were actually gonna pay
back the you know US debt and so some
people argue like it doesn't matter
because you can always just print your
way out of it some people argue that you
know literally you're gonna default on
the debt who knows but what I will say
is just like I think that we're we're
headed in the wrong direction rather
than the right one at Ulysses LF 99 what
keeps you going after the setbacks again
I'm just havin fun like the setbacks are
yeah they're super frustrating in the
short term but I always just kind of
look around I'm like I got a pretty good
life and I don't really work about worry
about that stuff nor do I get super
stressed so Scott chill all right
Fitzgerald 9 what is the exit scenario
look like for you can you retire from
creating content what would you do if
you're not doing this and yeah literally
one day I'm gonna wake up and just stop
but like what are you gonna do after
that just sit read hang out with my
friends hang out please so you genuinely
do enjoy sighs you want to do it yeah
because you're learning of course
everything that I do with people
forgetting everything I do is I'm
learning so when I'm writing I'm
learning we're exact to go read a bunch
of stuff and understand it and kind of
put my thoughts down on paper all that
stuff the podcast same thing Twitter
like Twitter's an amazing learning
engine in terms and I can put ideas out
in the world and immediately get
feedback on them you know everything is
just learning and it's not that I'll
stop wanting to learn it's just that at
some point I'll literally just wake up
and be like this way of learning is not
we're gonna be something else alright
question from Sherdog millionaire at SH
man underscore D why do you tornado
emoji in your Twitter bio I think I put
it there because like tornadoes just
kind of like go through places like
screw stuff up and then just like keep
on going like they're just like
literally on a warpath and they get
where they're going and nothing can stop
them and I put that up there like years
ago and I just was like I've never taken
it down and so it's been there so long I
kind of feel like I would I'd be
cheating on myself to be down at this
point okay oh man what company is my
biggest stock position somebody
responded to the ready but yeah I'm not
in the public market so no public stock
I own is gbtc admire some of my
retirement account and I don't own any
other public stocks okay I think you've
answered this but what at King Jesus 3
what percentage of your own net worth is
in cryptos it's more than 50% and it's
all about Bitcoin yeah it's all bit
quiet 50 percent there's two financial
systems so there's a legacy financial
system and there's an alternative
financial system to legacy systems an
inflationary system you with the US
dollars the core unit of account the
alternative system is a deflationary
system that has Bitcoin as the core unit
of account I believe that there is at
least a 50% chance that the deflationary
Bitcoin based system is going to be the
the new system in the future and so I'm
willing to take a 50/50 bet it's a
little bit more fit than 50/50 on I'm
kind of Bitcoin world and if I'm wrong I
understand also the risk that I will
lose 50% of my net worth but I'm
comfortable doing that I'm a relatively
young guy and I tend to think that on
make it back pretty quickly so not worry
about it at Anwar a douche a how will
crypto relate with third world economies
being in wealth distribution or use
cases I think everything like the system
changes and so therefore you'll get a
complete redistribution of wealth in
terms of there's a lot of people who
hold Bitcoin who aren't necessarily
wealthy in u.s. dollars
they did everything from earning it to
mining it to buying it whatever and if
it becomes the global reserve currency
there's a lot of wealth that I get
created obviously but on top of that I
also think that there is incredible
resetting of the economies and so you
know I just think that it was it is kind
of all-encompassing and then the other
thing I'd say is I also think bitcoin is
a market expanding technology so if you
look at uber if most people looked at it
they would have compared to the taxi
industry at first it ended up not only
kind of attacking taxis but then
literally now people don't have cars
because they use uber all the time right
and so it was a way to expand the taxi
market or the total addressable market
was much bigger than people originally
realized I definitely think that coin is
going to be much bigger than people
realize the total addressable market
it's not just the money supply but I
actually think that the total
addressable market is all stored value
assets so things like real estate like
or etc can all get a lot of that value
can get sucked back into hard currency
or kind of a sound money currency like
Bitcoin and so I tend to think that it's
a hundred plus trillion dollar
opportunity we're currently sitting at
about you know call it 200 billion
dollars so we got you know a long ways
500 X but now 500 X is not going to be a
straight line
I tend to think that it's gonna be
incredibly volatile and when I say you
know 500 X kind of is total addressable
market doesn't mean that Bitcoin
captures the entire addressable market
it could only penetrate a small
percentage and if it does reach a high
percentage of the market it could take
decades to do so a little bit of this
could be a 50-plus year exercise and so
you know I say all that when I when
people hear me say 500 x-type potential
don't think that's gonna happen
overnight
please don't make investment decisions
based on this stuff I have no clue what
I'm talking about all the normal
disclaimers but but I do think that
that's kind of the ultimate bowl cases
kind of what the adjustable market looks
like all right so I think we've gotten
through most of everything awesome
questions guys at super Mars 87 asks
in-depth thoughts on aliens yeah I mean
I've pretty much shared this stuff so I
believe aliens are real and since that
other intelligent life exists somewhere
in the world
or in the galaxy I guess the I am
personally fascinated with just the
expansiveness of space and my biggest
question is not whether they exist or
not I think that it's a pretty you know
mathematically easy to prove case that
it is highly probable that they exist we
don't know with a hundred percent
certainty but but definitely very
probable my bigger question is just are
we on the same time scale meaning that
do we as humans exist on this specific
planet at the same time that intelligent
life exists on another planet or instead
do we end up living at a certain time in
kind of the the timeline of all of these
galaxies and the other intelligent life
ends up living and existing it's just on
a different time scale so you know they
come 100 billion years after us and we
never actually kind of cross paths who
knows super she didn't think about you
know I Bruce Fenton came on he's an
ancient alien researcher he said the two
questions that every human asks during
their life is what happens after we die
and are we here alone I think that's a
great way to kind of look at from a
framework standpoint and the second
thing is I've got a friend house closest
who basically says all time that
probably at this point the most
important discovery that could happen in
human history is the discovery of other
intelligent life more so than figuring
out how to solve cancer or any of that
stuff not so much that it would have an
impact but just it would drastically
change the way that billions of people
look at their life the world and how we
relate to some kind of space so I tend
to think that people like Tom DeLonge
and others who are spending a lot of
time money and resources and mental
energy on this are doing really
important work and you know that's why I
asked everyone about it is because I'm
just looking to learn okay final
question
good because I'm losing my voice at
classic grass what are the Westerners
views on crypto adoption Africa and when
is your overall view on the African
economy I think Africa as a continent is
going to be one of the most important
continents and it's mainly because most
of the use cases in the United States
specifically are more around speculation
and it as an investment asset
but actually when you look around the
world there are many places and many of
them are developing countries obviously
Africa has a lot of those where this is
like actually needed on the ground in
terms of having decentralized technology
to settle value as a medium of exchange
and also to serve as a true store of
value where you could have a hundred
percent certainty that no one is
manipulating that currency and so from
that standpoint I tend to think that
Africa is really important
some people know that some people don't
I went to Nigeria about three years ago
I spent I think was a week or two there
and I was blown away I was blown away by
one of the demographics how fast it was
growing how big the country will be on a
population basis how young it is how
technologically advanced it is and also
I was blown away just by I think the the
intellectual curiosity again of people I
mean I literally went and watched a
football match in someone's backyard at
like a viewing center where they hope to
have a bunch of TVs with satellites in
their backyard and had built like almost
like a cinema if you will or like a
watching state center I went and I went
to a bedding area where literally people
were bidding on video games that were
being played on simulation mode I went
to computer village I want all these
different places and so it was just a
really really cool experience I think to
see how people who grew up in a very
different lifestyle than me on an
entirely different continent that most
people don't go to kinda what their
life's like and frankly it when I left I
actually wrote a piece I think on medium
or something that said like Nigeria is
going to be one of the technology hubs
of the future and I tend to think that
all the trends and value and kind of
good things that Nigeria has going
forward there's a lot of other places on
the continent of Africa you know kind of
apply there as well so super bullish on
the entire continent really anything
else no all right guys do me a huge
favor go check out block by block fight
comm slash pop go check out choice
retire with choice comm slash pop and go
sign up for the newsletter for not
already signed up pomp letter calm
that's it
appreciate guys listening thank you so
much to plan it for helping sorry that
the lighting sucks the video quality
sucks but
we're doing our best here and let's do
this again and I'll leave you guys with
one parting word which simply is just
thank you I guess that's two words it's
one saying just thank you guys for
listening super super helpful to me
obviously I really enjoy kind of all the
back and forth on Twitter responses to
the newsletter everything and hopefully
you guys are learning much so I
appreciate it and I'll try to do this
more often but just thank you